these people are my friends and i care
about them
okay
i am born fire james bond fire michael
scott
what a cute bench thanks that's my bed
no
no
okay tuna
you know pam in spain they often don't
even start eating until midnight when in
rome hmm
that is sort of an oaky afterbirth
[Music]
look at him he's laughing
you can buy new stuff but you can't buy
a new party ah does anybody read the
paper
i'm in hell
i'm burning help me you shouldn't joke
about that
yeah
what
just put it in front of my face yeah
hello
dwight brought glasses and a person step
stop step step step step you have no
idea the physical toll the three
vasectomies have on a person i hate my
life
so can we come in
hmm
quite turkey leg
the thought of popping one of your beets
into my mouth makes me want to vomit i
can't prove it
but i think she might be trying to
poison me you know i have soft teeth how
could you say that purely carnal that's
all you need to know email
oh
okay that's nice everybody enjoying
their meal
i am a screenwriter and i'm a
candlemaker but you don't hear me
bragging about it you're hardly my first
that's what you said
[Music]
that is a 200 plasma screen tv you just
killed
i'm gonna get going uh what seems to be
the problem officers not now dwight just
a couple of friends having an awesome
dinner party my girlfriend
threw a dundee at my tv oh my
apartment's on fire flooded flooded
you're sleeping with me no
[Music]
you took
[Music]
[Music]
yes i would babe
baby
baby bye babe babe are you ma'am
you took me
[Music]
[Music]